and as hard as that is and i know how
much love is behind it when
mulled wine stands are set up when
waffle bakeries are set up it
is not compatible with the
agreement that we
only eat and eat to take
home, for example, really an agreement
i'm sorry but it  i'm really
sorry in my heart but if we
pay the price for the fact that we have death numbers of
590 people a day then
that's not acceptable from my point of view
that's why we have to and when
science and downright flees from
christmas before grandma and grandpa
grandparents and older people sees
a week of contact reduction to
enable then maybe we
should think again if we don't
find some way to not let the holidays start
until the 19th
but maybe
already on the 16th what will you do then in
retrospect on an event of the century
say if we weren't able
for these three days,
say somebody  to find your solution and
say yes
it may be that lifting
compulsory schooling is the wrong thing then
it has to be digital lessons or something
since i don’t know it’s
not my competence either i would go to
the local i will say so then
we now have too many
contacts before christmas and then it was the
last time with the grandparents
then we must have missed something
that we would have a chair
[applause]